we would like to take this opportunity
to officially welcome you to today's
session forecasting disruption how to
think about the future in a rapidly
changing world with Bill Bernett and
Cynthia Benjamin now we'll turn it over
to our presenters for
introductions thanks Annette that's
great um happy to see everybody here
we're gonna have a really interesting
conversation about the uh the future of
you know technology in this crazy
rapidly changing world so um we've got a
couple of amazing pres well one amazing
presenter and then just me let me let me
introduce Cynthia Benjamin she is the
co-founder and chief strategy and
Innovation offer officer of together
senior health which is a digital health
care company working in the um
Alzheimer's and Dementia space she's
also been a lecture at Stanford for a
bunch of years um has taught a couple of
different programs a fantastic class
called me 101 visual thinking but
currently a class me 297 that is called
forecasting for innovators and she's
going to be leading us through some
forecasting uh strategies U for this
particular
webinar thanks Bill um and let me
introduce Bill Bernett um bill is uh an
adjunct professor in the de Design Group
at Stanford um he's actually been the
executive director of the uh the design
IMPACT program and undergrad program for
gosh a long time B you're GNA have to
remind me how many years about 15 about
15 years um and before that uh Bill had
a distinguished career as a design
leader a designer and a design leader at
Apple at counter toys at several
startups um and so has a depth of
experience in in uh design and design
education he's also a co-author of a
book called designing your life which
has uh come out came out of Stanford but
really resonated deeply um across a wide
swath of folks from people um thinking
about what they're going to do coming
out of college to uh what they might do
in their oncore career um and then a
second book designing your new work life
um so belill H really happy to to share
this webinar with you yeah this is going
to be a lot of fun um you know in the
designing your life curriculum we think
about five-year Futures and that's
actually what we're going to be talking
about here but we're going to be talking
about it through the lens of design
thinking and also technologies that are
impacting our world today so for those
of you who you've probably heard of the
phrase design thinking or maybe human
centered design is what we used to call
it um we have uh started the David Kelly
who started the D school at Stanford our
Institute to teach design thinking
basically to the world said design
thinking is all about unlocking
potential and the creative confidence of
of our students David's book creative
confidence that he wrote with his
brother Tom Kelly uh was also a big hit
um and you know this idea of design
thinking although the D school started
in 2006 our programming design goes back
to the 60s all the way you know back to
even 1957 when we taught the very first
class um uh in design and it's always
been a mixture of design art psychology
sociology we like to think about
designing and designers way of thinking
as as a as a powerful problem solving
tool it's a process we say you don't
start with a problem you start with
people you start with empathy and really
try to understand deeply what are the
what are the issues that people are
facing and what are the ways in which
you might solve some of those problems
you know we're going to talk a lot about
technology and Technology Futures today
but both Cynthia and I have share the
opinion of lots of startups you know
start with a technology first and then
go try to figure out who needs it in the
design thinking process we would do the
exactly the opposite first we try to
understand what's the real deep human
need and not just the need that people
describe when you talk to them but what
what's really going on past what they
say and do to what they really think and
feel so we start with empathy we
redefine the problem we come up with
lots of ideas because we know if we have
lots of ideas we'll have better choices
and then the whole idea of prototyping
of Designing little experiments to to to
tweak the future and see what it's all
about
prototyping and testing is the strategy
for building our way forward so design
thinking it's kind of the undercurrent
of everything we do in the Design Group
at Stanford it's a really you know it's
interesting it's a it's a dynamic
approach to problem solving because we
use lots of you know techniques like
brainstorming and mind mapping and we'll
talk about some of those today but it's
also using prototyping and and Rapid
cycles of iteration and experimentation
to figure out how to increase the
innovation of outcomes but more than
that it's a really great approach to
problem finding and you know one of my
favorite quotes from Peter duer the sort
of business Guru you know management
Professor um is um there's there's
nothing quite so foolish as doing
something very very well that never
needed to be done in the first place and
that describes a lot of the technology
startups we see in Silicon Valley that
start with some cool piece of technology
and never find a need for it so problem
finding is where we think there's the
highest leverage when we reframe
problems based on human needs and we use
ethnography empathic observations and
other techniques that we borrow from
anthropology and sociology to truly
understand what users need and what's
the best problem to solve and because of
that we believe it's been it's become a
new perspective on value creation
because when you can match a human-
centered need to an actual technology
and into a market that's that's large
and robust you have you know a really
fantastic way of creating Innovation and
value
creation So today we're going to talk a
little bit about this idea of
forecasting and design thinking because
you know the needs and design principles
that we use to create startups or new
products or or new actions in the
marketplace these change over time and
certainly we're we're in the period
right now with things like AI chat GPT
robotics automation where where things
are changing rapidly and so the needs of
of people consumers organizations uh
everybody the needs are changing rapidly
over time and if we don't have some way
of putting kind of
a structure around this or at least a a
framework around how we think about the
future we can we can really fall behind
and so forecasting changes and tracking
technology we think is really critical
to any any design or innovation strategy
and that's why for oh I don't know know
you and Paul Sappo have been teaching
this class for over 15 years in the
Design Group we really support the
notion that we have to not just think
about what do people need today but
what's going to change as technology
evolves in the next five 10 even 50
years so that's what we're going to be
talking about um and and Cynthia why you
know you're the you're the expert on
this on this subject why should
innovators you know and people who might
want to come to the workshop we going to
be running in March
um people who might be the CTO or the
person in charge of the Innovation
organization at their company or
somebody who's um an entrepreneur
thinking about uh the application of new
technologies why is it important for
them to think about their
future well for uh it's really important
for a lot of reasons if you want to uh
be competitive if you want to bring real
Innovation out to the
marketplace um you know everything is
connected right it's both obvious and
and not right A lot of times we think
about our Innovations in isolation like
if I just do this cool thing you know
better mouse trap will you know people
will beat a path to my door but in real
life everything is connected and so it's
important to think strategically about
the future um and and you'll have a real
Advantage if you understand the context
of your Innovation both how we got to
this place the history of it and
possible futures um the
one of the reasons that we apply design
Thinking Tools here is um the very first
thing youal Bill talked about in design
thinking it's it's these are are pro
tricky problems without a lot of
boundaries and um and design Thinking
Tools can be really helpful in that
context um and you know if you want to
build Sustainable Solutions that are
around for a long time not just for
today it's important to think about the
context of of your your Innovation um
and you the biggest problems are pretty
complex if you want to have real impact
in the world applying these kinds of
tools to to bring some boundaries to the
problem to think creatively about
Alternatives and not just build on the
first hypothesis that pops into mind
um these are these are great tools for
for thinking that way um and then lastly
this this last bullet it's kind of
important the future can have a range of
possible outcomes right a lot of times
we think about forecasting in the same
way we think about prediction and it's
not about predicting the future because
that's you know we don't have a crystal
ball and in fact actions that we take
today can impact the future actions that
we take tomorrow can impact the future
so there are a range of possibilities
out there um not just one and so if
we're thinking strategically about um
how we want to play in the future how we
want to win in the future how we want to
influence uence the future it's
important to understand that range of
possible outcomes and that cone of
uncertainty that um that I'll refer to
again later um and and then you can
decide where you want to play and where
you can have a real
Advantage um so let me just put a little
bit of a framework out here that we'll
talk through today and I'll talk through
an example as well um a lot of times
when we start uh thinking about
forecasting um we will pick we will
Define a central question and what I
mean by that is like what's the area
that you want to be thinking about um a
lot of times we think about oh what's
the world going to look like in 20 years
which is an interesting question but
it's it gets so many variables that that
it's it's hard to to wrap your head
around much less make some predictions
about that can be useful so um we want
to make this useful we want to make this
something that you can take away and
take some action about if you're
thinking about you know 20 years from
now what's the world going to look like
that that that's hard to that's an
interesting conversation but it's not um
not anything that you can really bring
into today and take action on so we want
to focus
on some boundaries about what is you
know what is the question that we want
answers to um in this particular
exercise um the next thing that that we
spend a fair amount of time doing in
class and obviously we won't spend a lot
of time today but talking about the
context of the space that you're looking
at figuring out how we got here um and
and doing some research doing some
background and or bringing in experts
who know the space that that you're
playing in it's important to understand
the context so that one you don't
reinvent the wheel um which we see a a
lot of um you know people come coming
out with some great Innovation turns out
somebody already did that and in fact
maybe they failed a few years ago and
you could have learned something if you
had just understood what happened with
them um uh so so kind of getting getting
the lay of the land um then look around
for what are the drivers of of change in
the space what are the key elements that
are going to drive change in the space
that you're interested in and pulling
out some insight into you know which
which ones are important which ones are
going to have the biggest impact where's
the biggest uncertainty in the space
going forward um and and pulling you
know pull extracting those out so then
you can think about what possible
outcomes could there be what what are
the different Futures that could happen
in my space um which ones are most
likely and and putting some structure
around that can be helpful so that then
you can think about your options and
take action why do you care how will you
participate in these Futures if the the
vast uh range of possibility um uh if
the range of possibility is vast how
will you manage that how will you learn
about the future what should you be
looking for between here and there to
understand which of these possible
Futures is likely to emerge so we have
this structure that we use um in the
class that bill referred to um me 297
forecasting for innovators and you know
we'll take St students through this week
by week and we work with we work in
teams um and it's a great way to both
explore a new area if students want to
explore someplace new or to go deeper
into an area of
expertise um so I'm going to take you
through this process and we're going use
an example as well so the first thing as
I mentioned is about a central question
broadly defining the space with a Grand
aspirational
Vision um and characteristics of a good
Central question are are to make it
interesting essentially you're not
hypothesizing a future but you are
thinking about what's a good question to
ask that's going to stimulate thinking
and thought-provoking it depends on this
it depends on that um uh it might be a
hypothesis but the point is to generate
generate learning at at this first stage
so we're going to talk about robotics
for this example here today um and a
question that people might set might ask
would be what does the future of
Robotics look like which is interesting
but that's kind of a researchy question
and it's kind of boring how about a
question instead of when will a human
marry a
robot so and I like that question
because it it makes you kind of stop and
think for a minute like what what would
that mean what would that look like and
and it could could stimulate a fair
amount of debate some people might think
well that's pretty close in some folks
might think well that'll never never
happen um but what it does is is it it
kind of gets you thinking about what the
next questions
are oh and and the next question should
be about context like how did we get
here um understanding how things have
changed in this space um design TP and
the design tools that we use typically
solve problems for today and can be
super useful about need finding
understanding users um understanding the
issues but in designing for tomorrow
some of these design tools allow us to
understand the history of this space the
technology that is in place today um and
the rate of change which can be actually
pretty pretty important when we think
about Innovation and
Technology we're often optimistic that
this is gonna this is going to happen
really fast but you know some of these
questions about robotics that we're
looking at here today in this example
are the same questions we were asking 10
years ago
and 10 years before that um and so the
rate of change is really important um
change around some of the Technologies
is is pretty rapid the rate of change
around some of the cultural factors some
of the the ways that we use robotics it
can be much slower and
and when you think about how those are
connected or linked together um that's
where you really start to understand
what are the factors that could either
accelerate or potentially impede
adoption of this technology that we're
working on the other reason I look at
context don't reinvent the wheel
oftentimes there's some things out there
that you may not have been aware of that
you could build off of or leverage or
learn
from so the next piece um is where we're
going to spend a little bit more time
here today so thinking about driving
forces and the drivers of change we like
to think about three types of of driving
forces I'm going to start at the bottom
here instead of the top um
technology um technology is where a lot
of change happens and it can be quite
rapid um and that's where a lot of
innovators kind of focus heavily on um
but we might also Overlook some use
cases uh or culture these are the things
that that that need to align to bring
adoption to adopt change um over time um
and all of these things will feed into
the The Innovation going forward so um
let's start let's start here talking
about technology um let's go back to the
example that I brought up of a central
question when will a human marry a
robot so technology that needs to be in
place
for you know imagine imagine yourself
out there in the future or one of your
children or somebody coming to to the
place where they would consider miroring
a robot what are the scientific
breakthroughs or the technological
advances that that need to have happened
um to make a machine functional as a
human partner that's somebody you'd want
to want to marry so let's Bill let's
chat a little bit about about that here
what what are some of the technologies
that you think might need to be in place
to to to marry a
robot well
um You' probably want to have uh
certainly some kind of a you know a
physical instance of the thing that it
wasn't scary or weird um you'd probably
want to have something you could talk to
you know we wouldn't have to type input
or something like that you could talk
and have a sort of a normal conversation
of some sort
um and you know if you're thinking about
a you know a life
partner um versus just a robot that you
know cooks and cleans or something thing
then um I kind of I mean I kind of I'm
kind of a hopeless romantic I want
something with a little soul with a
little bit of uniqueness with something
you know interesting or curious for me
to learn about because I don't want I
don't want a machine machine is
predictable I want something that's a
little more well human yeah yeah so yeah
there are a bunch of technologies that
would need to come together to even
create something that we could start to
think about partnering with over time
right and some things you know as as
straightforward as sensor technology
like can this thing make its way through
the world does this thing recognize that
I am its partner right so Vision
Technologies communication Technologies
speech language um battery power like
does is my partner going to get plugged
into the wall or is my partner going to
be out in the world with me um Mobility
things like you know some Bas some some
basic building blocks of this thing that
could that that I could partner with so
there's a lot of technology that would
need to be in place here for
sure um so let's think about use cases
then so use cases I what I mean by use
cases are these kind of intermediary
products or services or functions that
would need to come together to create a
desirable life partner so like so Bill
you mentioned you know empathy but um
you know some kind of
companionship right there's that's or or
um you know intimacy right that's a use
case that would combine some of the
technologies that one might expect in
one's life
partner um you know a household support
service is another use case like you
know picture the robot in in the Jetson
right so wouldn't it be awesome if we
all had that that you know the kind of
characteristics of a
household household support person other
other use cases what do you think
Bill well how might we use robots in
this interim
period yeah well you mentioned Mobility
I mean you know I want to I want to
travel with my partner I want to get on
an airplane and you go places I wanna
you know I want to rent a car and I want
them to be able to drive it or maybe
it'll be an autonomous car and they can
just you know Jack in and tell it where
you want to go but if you think about um
if you think about all the emotional
aspects of
companionship um it gets pretty tricky
to you know to think about creating a
machine that has that kind of emotional
depth yeah yeah it does it does and so
let's actually start let's think also
then about some of the cultural drivers
of change like that would that what are
some social or political or legal or
regulatory issues that might emerge as
we think about people marrying machines
so this is where things get really you
know pretty pretty tricky
like would it be legal Mar a machine
right
yeah if you think about the legal thing
I mean we assume that when two people
get married they can give consent I want
to marry this person I'm not being
forced to do so I want to marry this how
can a machine give consent we don't have
I mean doesn't that
require of Consciousness or
intelligence um and uh you know I mean I
think you know you look at some cultures
like Japan where robotics has been
adopted for you know elder care and
other things they might be more open to
this but I think in the US um people
would be kind of freaked out if I was
you know sitting at a nice restaurant
having dinner with a
robot and why why would that and if the
robot actually has you know free will to
marry you as opposed to being your
servant um if they don't have free will
like it starts to open up all sorts of
interesting interesting kind of cultural
societal
questions um yeah one
that robot for divorce yeah would a
robot file for divorce or what about
procreation are you you going to have
children with your robot whoa what does
your legacy look like will you even need
a will because your robot might live
forever and you obviously won't you have
a human body so all sorts of interesting
questions start to emerge around this
kind of cultural side of
of you know of this question whereas you
know if you're just thinking about the
technology side you might think yes we
could physically build a robot that you
could marry but but wow like you know
what's the setting of of this the
culture so I think this this is a great
way to think about um you know what are
some of those underlying drivers of
adoption or something that might impede
adoption of Robotics in general so even
though you know we're focused on this
question of you know Mar human marrying
a robot we're also eliciting all sorts
of questions that are relevant even if
I'm I'm not looking at marriage but I
want to understand the future of robot
otics in general because all of these
things will come into play as we as a
society adopt you know more robotics
into our
world um this this this stuff has come
up in in like factories right where
robots are working side by side with
human workers and the human workers are
unionized and the robots are not and
then there's all these debates and is it
even safe to work next to a robot
because the robot you know has no no
sense of you know the human being
fragile so it's really really I mean I
love this forcing question because
although miring a robot may be a little
bit extreme you can easily you know kind
of down select to to situations we're
already in where robots are working
Amazon wants to have all their factories
full of robots you know but there's
still people there so how do we how do
we navigate these important you know
like cultural and use case issues right
right you know there also I think some
great examples out there of of places
we've gotten stuck in this technology
level right thinking that technolog is
going to drive change all on its own you
know you we're talking earlier about um
uh you know the VR glasses right
Google's doing these glasses Apple's
done the glasses um snap has done these
glasses and it's this really cool
technology but nobody's adapted them and
and and I think it's because one there
haven't been real good use cases for
them there are some very Niche use cases
around um you know kind of medical
Robotics and things like that where that
could be really relevant but there
aren't a lot of use cases so people
haven't started to use this and getting
and gotten comfortable with them and
from a cultural
perspective we kind of as a group of
people have not yet decided that walking
around with you know with computers on
our faces is comfortable or useful or or
societally acceptable um so no matter
how great that technology might be it's
it's not it's it's not adapted well and
it's a perfect example also of Looking
Backward in technology people think you
know Apple's Vision Pro wow it's brand
new or the Oculus that you know Meta
Meta stuff is based on the Oculus
headset but you know I had friends in
the 80s who started a company called
face spak face space fake space labs and
they were doing VR with two CRT te's
literally two two televisions on a
balanced boom that you could put your
face in and you could have the exact
same experience you're having today and
all that's happened is the technology
got faster it got smaller it got lighter
but still you know in whatever that is
50 years nobody's come up with a
reason that I want to do this VR or AR
stuff and that that it would be
acceptable in our culture to be wearing
you know like I said a computer on my
face yeah so we got a long way to go we
got a long way to go so let's pop back
to some methods here and and um think
about what you do with with these
drivers right so there's lots of ways to
think about generating this list of of
drivers of change one is discussion like
we're having another might be a a tool
like an idea map that we use a lot in in
design and design thinking B you want to
take just a minute and talk about what
you know how you might use this kind of
tool sure IDE maps are sometimes they're
called called mind maps are just a great
way of really you know Loosely exploring
an area and being um very know um you
know using using your both your
intuition and your sort of creative mind
to kind of quickly map out all the ideas
that are connected so you have something
idea in the center this case it might be
Robotics and and autonomy or Robotics
and a robot that you can marry and then
off of that you you brainstorm a few uh
options and then off of that you
brainstorm options off of each of those
and as the Mind map gets bigger and
bigger it brings in more and more of the
different domains and it's not limited
to just the technology piece you can
have you know a whole a whole part of
the map might just be around the um the
use cases a whole part of the map might
be around the cultural or social issues
and it's just a great way of a team
really fleshing out all of the
connections and interconnections between
uh the central idea and lots and lots of
other ideas it's a great way to get
teams brainstorming to together as
well yeah great um and so here's an
example in this uh example that we've
been talking about where human Mir is a
robot so what we did was start you know
with an idea map and generating lots of
these different elements now I wouldn't
expect anybody to to actually read all
the little tiny things on this on this
screen but I wanted to share this kind
of as an overview in terms of like how
you might use an idea map to start
generating things put them up on a wall
and then you can start to group them and
we used in this case you know the blue
ones we started thinking about what were
the Technologies and the orange ones
were you know what were some of the use
cases and and you know applications of
Robotics and the green ones were about
society and culture but then we started
rearranging them on the wall because you
the last thing you want to do in a
brainstorming session is put a bunch of
Post-its on the wall and walk away
that's just a that's that's it feels
great in the moment and then then you
know immediately becomes useless so in
this case we started rearranging these
and started thinking about what were the
linkages what were the the how are they
connected um and what were some of the
most important um elements that we
wanted to consider going forward as we
were building a forecast in this space
so you can see things were circled there
lots of arrows um some things were
underlined and they like and and so
those were the things that we took
forward because to try to build a map
with you know with hundred elements here
it just doesn't make sense so you try
and figure out which ones are the
biggest impact and which ones have the
greatest
uncertainty so the and the top drivers
have have both because the things that
you know or can predict in you know
fairly reasonable ways are going to be
the underlying factors in in any future
but if you're trying to understand the
breadth of possible futures let's look
at the ones that we think will have the
biggest impact positively or negatively
or speed-wise um and which ones have the
greatest uncertainty because that's
going to kind of give us the breth of
possibility in our you know in our count
of
uncertainty so um we just I kind of skim
quickly through this example we took the
the items that were circled or squared
on that map we started just kind of
going through them in terms of impact
and UNC certainty so some of the things
that we identified and and you as you
look at these might think differently so
this is a tool for conversation it's
it's a you know qualitative tool
obviously um not quantitative and
there's a lot of of room for discussion
here so like which ones do you think
would have the highest impact and
highest uncertainty we picked empathy
like how do you even create empathy from
a technology perspective huge impact on
whether this is going to unfold how it's
going to unfold a lot of
uncertainty um learning as well seem you
know seem to be a a high high
companionship like we talked about
earlier um in terms of a use case uh
seemed pretty high impact how do we do
that what does that look like timing how
could that unfold and then interestingly
you know a bunch of these things under
culture um legal marriage so the the
legal elements around how we typically
think about marriage and somebody I see
in the Q&A ask like
what is even marriage should we be
talking about marriage in this space is
it a what would a legal Union look like
as opposed to a legal kind of a human
marriage it might evolve to be something
different or defined it differently um
and this notion of free will
uh can you know can a robot can we can
we build robots that have enough Free
Will and frankly if they have free will
will they want to marry us right like if
I that's a huge uncertainty and and and
you know and a huge impact on the answer
to this question so we you know because
I'm you know I'm a consultant and a
lecturer and all I like to put a little
framework on things and so for me it's
helpful to kind of graph those so what
are the things that have the highest
impact and the highest uncertainty and
those are the elements that are most
likely to tip the future one way or
another so those are things in the top
right here empathy learning
companionship the notion of legal
marriage Free Will relationship trust um
and when I do this it really helps me to
think of to look at things graphically
and so it it you know when I look at the
things in the bottom left low
uncertainty and low impact it's not that
they're not unimportant because they are
critical but you know creation of a
physical body somehow and even what do
the sensors development of sensors look
like um those are our
I wouldn't say predictable but but you
can foresee a pretty clear future in
development around sensor technology
right historically they've gotten you
know faster smaller more sensitive so I
think compared to some of these other
things that's a relatively
straightforward I would call that kind
of part of the landscape going forward I
would assume sensors will continue to
get smarter smaller you know better um
language I'm assuming that there's that
that the language which technologies
will continue to to you know get better
faster more useful some of these other
questions empathy I don't know what
that's going to look like right so um so
oftentimes it's it is the technology
pieces that are in this more predictable
part of the the landscape and some of
the cultural stuff that is the more
uncertain which I think it's kind of
interesting particularly for somebody
who is a technology person it's like oh
yeah there's all these other things so
what well how we would you know work
with this next is thinking about kind of
what order how do how do these things
relate to each other um I grabbed the
things from that top right the high
impact High empathy and kind of laid
them out I think we have to figure out
empathy before I begin to trust a a
machine I need to have trust in place
before I could build an actual
relationship with that machine um there
needs to have some sense of
relationships and we need to figure out
free will before we Define what a legal
marriage or a legal Union could look
like so just kind of generally laying
these things out and starting to think
about how they connect you know what
what order they're
in and then how they connect to each
other stting layering in some of these
other
factors um and you know we've got
physical body Mobility language sensors
in here that all need to get get you
know dealt with pretty early before we
can start to do these other things now
um I want to step here for a second
because and reference the the workshop
that bill you're going to talk about at
the end here um as we look at the um
expertise of the Stanford professors in
the engineering department um and the
students that are working today in the
you the phds and the labs and the lake a
lot of them are making huge advances in
these technology areas and some of them
in the the kind of the use case areas as
well and so you know going deep into
these elements gives you a lot more
information about how they connect to
the other the other elements um and I
just would encourage people as they're
going deep into these spaces to think
about kind of what either what are the
technologies that underly them and or
what are the the cultural factors that
that need to be in play for
adoption so after after we kind of lay
these things out let's build some stor
stories let's get to that um that cone
of uncertainty
so you know you can you can lay these
out and start thinking about that you
know the top piece of this gets us to
legal marriage so let's say the first
things out there are you know robots
around sax and intimacy some might say
that some of those exist today right
household service Bots um you know maybe
next thing is uh you know is starting to
build some relationships with these um
AI you know friends um skin motion pain
replicated fully mobble humanoid um
because most most of us when we picture
a human miring a robot it's a humanoid
robot you're not marrying a box right
it's unlikely that you could have all of
these things in place with you know with
with with a big metal box um
but then what happens when you've got a
fully mobile humanoid um that maybe has
free will well maybe robots are going to
start doing things independently because
they have free will they might want to
be citizens they might want to vote
right they might want to have Choice um
and probably at that that's the only
point where I can imagine legal marriage
kind of being redefined to include being
married to some kind of artificial
intelligence and that's you know that's
a a a it's a reasonable story it's a
rational story um and it's an outcome
that when you understand the elements of
it is not it's not out of the realm of
possibility flip side of that is when
you start thinking about how some of
those elements might turn out
differently um you know in terms of of
some of the elements that we've talked
about realistic conversation has got to
be in place high capacity batteries have
got to be in place but what if we get to
a place where that uncanny valley Still
Remains and we're not able to build
these humanoid robots that are that are
good enough so that we start to to kind
of back away from the notion of of
robots as human and start moving towards
robots that are embedded in our
environment which is also a a a a future
that could make a lot of sense right you
walk into your home and you don't have a
humanoid service robot you just walk in
your home and say do my laundry
home it's just you know go make this
happen world around me um and so the
robots are not humanoid at all maybe
they're just embedded around us and we
and and they they start to become of our
world
and and so then kind of trust issues
evolve a little bit differently um and
maybe they're so embedded in our world
that we don't need people anymore in a
lot of places first grown adult with no
other human contact you know there have
been some
sci-fi books and movies written with
this future in mind and it's it's also
plausible given what we just talked
about all of those elements if they
don't turn out one way they might turn
out a different way and combine in a
wholly different way where we are here
for the robot
as opposed to the robots being here for
us and so you know building out these
stories gives us a sense of the the
range of possibility um and you can you
know you can look across these and
see uh See kind of a baseline future
where robots are are starting as service
elements for us then we start to build
relationships with them and then they
find some kind of Independence and it's
that that that range of things around
Independence can be kind of scary but
you also can see how it starts much
earlier to move towards one side or the
other so as we think about you know
range of possibilities why do we care
what can you do with this information
right where does your company fit in um
are you working in a technology company
that uh will enable any future going
forward which would be good to know um
are you working in a space that kind of
will depend on one future or another um
you know when we talk when I talk with
my students a lot of them want to know
you know I don't like they'll come at
this and say I don't like this
particular future I don't want the world
to come out where you know we are here
for the robots so what can I do today to
influence the future what can I do today
if knowing that this is a possibility um
how can I think about influencing the
future or playing along in the future or
leveraging the future um but knowing
that this is the range of outcomes and
that these are the things that are
likely to unfold um can give you a real
leg up no matter how you want to play in
this particular
space so I'm gon to wrap up there on the
Robotics and the forecasting um and see
questions
or I just want I wanted to jump in on a
couple of things here because it's such
an interesting idea um there's a comment
in the CH chat about oh hey they already
have companion robots in Japan and
that's true nothing like what we're
talking about but it is one of the
things I would put on the chart they got
little dogs that you know run around and
bark they've got little companions but
it's also interesting because um Japan
is going to be a super aging Society in
the next 10 years a v vast number of
Japanese are over 55 or 60 and in other
parts of Asia the the home care for your
for old for your older you know adults
for your your parents um has been solved
by importing inexpensive you know
caregivers from different parts of the
world I I used to have an office in Hong
Kong many people in Hong Kong have um
you know Hospital helpers that they
brought in from the Philippines from
Indonesia from other places and that's
how they take care of their Elders Japan
because of cultural issues has decided
not to do that they don't they don't
bring
they don't allow that kind of
immigration so instead they've turned to
robotics as a solution but it's a really
interesting sort of extreme case right
where the obvious solution is to go find
some really compassionate caregiver to
take care of grandma and instead the
Japanese for cultural reasons would
prefer um to offload that to a robot and
there was even a fun movie made about
this where
the there was a robot who was sort you
know helping a an older guy Age and and
um and so you know the the the cultural
issue there is critical the other one
that I that you brought up which I think
is really interesting to think about is
trust I'm not even sure I trust my bank
with my financial information because
they get hacked all the time I'm
certainly not sure that I trust you know
some of the big companies in Silicon
Valley with my personal data which they
seem to like to sell all the time and
somebody's going to make and sell this
robot and I really want to know what
that maker you what the you know robots
are us company that sold me my compion I
really want to know what they're going
to do with the data that's generated
with with that because the probably the
most personal data is the data about the
person I
love so wow I mean it's just I mean
again it's an extreme question but I
think the extreme question brings out
all these interesting combinations of of
you know what's culture what's
technology what's a use case and that's
the kind of stuff that I think really
drives an interesting conversation about
what's the next five years the next 10
years going to look like and at the rate
of
change that we're seeing right now with
things like chat gb4 and and other AI
you know implementation starting to
flood into the marketplace we're we're
at what we think is a point of
incredible disruption and that's why we
put together um this webinar to talk a
little bit about casting but also the um
the program going to run in March for
two and a half days live on the Stanford
campus aren't you dying to get out of
your office now that coid is over and
finally go to a live thing where we're
gonna have amazing uh researchers
showing us what they're doing in
robotics and autonomy and Ai and other
things so that we can build for your own
organization these kinds of um
forecasting tools to get you walk away
with a forecast for the next five years
for what you think's going to happen
happen in your organization and
particularly this idea of the cone of
uncertainty what happens if everything
goes great what happens if everything
goes south I think that's that's exactly
the kind of way we should be thinking
about the
future so I think um Anette are you
gonna can you C
question well first first and foremost
thank you and Cynthia for such a an a
fascinating discussion I think a lot of
folks were um very engaged uh so we will
open it up to questions short if you
haven't submitted yours please do so in
the Q&A box if you have one um WR on
your console um now let's go into some
questions the first the first one we
have here what are the key drivers of
change in our world today and how might
they evolve in the coming
years that's a that's a big question
really really big question and and I
would suggest breaking it apart a little
bit
right um you know you can see how
putting some constraints around the
initial question can allows you to go
deep and then kind of surface back up to
questions that are relevant like a lot
of these questions that came up are
relevant to society in general and
understanding kind of how this world is
going to evolve but we didn't get there
by starting like starting with that huge
question like how's the world going to
change it's a
valid question for sure but it's not a
not necessarily a useful way to get to
answers right so I would suggest coming
up with some provocative question here
and I'll bet when we started this folks
were going yeah yeah pickle pick a
question and then go for it but then
when you do this you realize that how a
a provocative question like that can
really help you kind of go deep into an
area and then come up with some answers
that that are more
broad yeah and just to add to build on
that I think the the the value of asking
a good question for instance if I'm a
policy maker and I'm thinking about you
know public policy uh in the city of San
Francisco for the next 10 years um what
are I what are my drivers well it's the
economics of the of the of the region
it's you know um that's certainly
climate change and how that's going to
impact you know um the region both for
for like where is it going to be safe to
live and how many seaw walls am I going
to have to build and blah blah blah but
when but if I have a if I have a focus
if I have a point of view or a lens to
look through then I can figure out what
the drivers are to say what are the you
know what are the mega drivers for the
world for the next 10 years um I'm not
sure you can get any traction on that
question because you end up with
generalities like well economics and
social unrest climate change World Peace
you know yeah useful you can't you can't
solve the problem so I think this is
where diving into a particular focus and
then fleshing out a cone of
uncertainty could raise the next level
of questions and then doing it again and
again you know you'll end up with five
or six of these kind of cones and
forecasts and then perhaps you could
synthesize something down to say well
you know if if if I am the President of
the United States my number one
priorities need to be X Y and Z but even
that is going to come through the lens
of what's good for the US rather than
the world so I think asking the right
question is is is critical you know to
get to something that's that's actually
actionable yeah you know and let me give
you another example so some other
questions that we have posed in this
class are um you we wanted to look at
healthcare for example pretty big topic
and the question that we posed was um uh
will will I or will the students in the
class um live to be 120 years
old will I live to be 120 so it's a
somewhat provocative question um it's
pretty it's fairly General but specific
to healthcare so that really allowed us
to dig into healthc care in an
interesting way and you know what are
not just longevity Technologies but
what's going on in you know biotech and
social services and what else is going
on in society that will kind of
accelerate or
impede longevity in these questions and
it got us to a lot of really interesting
questions about um you know about
retirement and social policy as well as
you know technology behind um you know
the field of longevity and other health
care issues so by asking a a a question
with some boundaries on it um in a
provocative way it really allows you to
open up and and go go deep and then open
up I love that um thank you I think the
next one is a is a great question around
um applicability of this methodology and
um this uh this participant would like
to know what is the role of a design
leader to apply forecasting into
corporate
strategy um I I love that question um I
think the role of a designer can be to
both you know provoke and put some
boundaries on stuff um you know I think
good design
often um thrives with a little bit of
constraint and kind of focusing on that
central question encouraging people to
um put some constraints on their
questions instead of you know what is
the future of Robotics like encouraging
people to to to put some you know
something down that we can all kind of
discuss and rally around um and then
bringing some of these design tools into
play Thinking about encouraging people
to think about Alternatives and
alternative futures um encouraging
people to think about the human side of
these questions not just the technology
side um I think a lot of design tools um
are part of this conversation and really
can
be great um next question um so let's
see what questions or Frameworks you use
to assess where one's analysis might be
wrong
my one's analysis might be
wrong um let me take yeah go ahead can
let me take a whack of that and then you
can follow up um that's the the whole
idea of this
is that we're using you know
brainstorming mind mapping design
principle somebody said can you use chat
to come up with driver sure why not I
use chat in my classes all the time as a
brainstorming tool chat doesn't know
what it's talking about but it's just
good at you know randomly generating you
know interesting work and interesting
things to think about but the whole idea
of you know forecasting a cone of
uncertainty is there there's no right or
wrong there's a probability that the
future will be this there's another
probability that the future will be
wildly different than that and a
different probability that will be the
negative of that and so when you look at
that then you and you think about your
own organization let's say you're in a a
pharmaceutical company and you're
thinking about you know drug drug
Discovery and Drug Sy Delivery Systems
for the future and where's that going to
and how can AI influence you know
speeding that up or you're a Energy
company you're trying to think about
transitioning to the green economy or
your uh you know tech company and your
you've got some brand new thing that you
want to make an app you know that has
something to do with AI and and um the
financial markets so you take these
tools and you start to think about
what's going to change in the
future and how can my company respond to
those changes and what's the likelihood
that the worst case is going to happen
and what's the likelihood that the best
case is going to happen so we're not
talking about you know coming again as
Cynthia said in the beginning we're not
predicting the future we're coming up
with a range of possibilities and
probabilities that the future can you
know can sit inside what I love phrase
the cone of uncertainty and a nice part
is you know you say you start with the
forecast and you so five years out and
you've got your cone blah blah blah a
year
later you're at a completely different
point in that cone of uncertainty right
and you can start all over again go so
these are the things that actually
happened this is how my assumptions
change what's the new cone so it becomes
a dynamic tool for thinking about the
future in a structured way without the
without getting into you know I'm right
or I'm wrong or I'm predicting or I'm
not
predicting all right I think that's
great let's see if we can get in you
know another question or two yeah let's
let's get into the next one um the next
one that I have here is can AI be
applied to leadership to a leadership
framework in the future will a I become
part of EX of executive of an executive
team as well what are your thoughts on
that certainly could
be um andd be surprised I'd be surprised
if it if it doesn't somehow become part
of the Executive Suite how so is a
different question right so um you know
using a framework like this I think
could really help us kind of tease out
what are those
possibilities um and then you then
you've got your own qu context for
asking that question why you know why do
you want to know that question because
you're an executive and you want to
figure that out or because you're a
shareholder and you want to invest in
more of that or less of that or because
you are an employee and you don't want
to be you know led by an AI or you do
want to be you know you think that's
great so the context really matters and
and kind of why you're asking that
question on you know in terms of what
you're going to do with that with that
information but I got to tell you I love
that um some of the questions here are
are being asked about kind of the the
framework and so many of them are being
asked about the content here and you
know and people have some really
interesting thoughts about you know
robots and Robotics and the future of of
Robotics which I really love that that
this is stimulating those kinds that
kind of thinking and that's that is
really the the value in a you know kind
of a framework like this to get get you
really
thinking this is
it's not you know you can talk about it
superficially oh I heard this in the
news I saw that in the news but to
really understand it you know having a
little bit of structure like this look
at all these awesome questions that have
come up and and the comments people are
making about you know ethics and and you
know the legal nature of Robotics and Ai
and how that's involved and all these
other interesting things so I'm I'm
really I'm really loving the the variety
of questions I wish we could share these
all out one one of the one thing about
about every question has an embedded
assumption in it so Will AI be part of
the Executive Suite um well in my con of
uncertainty AI replaces Executives
because if most of what Executives do is
try to make optimal decisions AI will be
better at it than they are now if you're
talking about leadership that's a
different thing but this is going to
force Executives to separate what they
do about decision making which isn't
leadership it's just management versus
leadership ship and so you know to me if
you look at the the changes that are
coming why would I pay an investment
banker 2% of my you know of my fortune
to invest for me when I can hire an AI
That's going to outperform that that
Human by 10% why would I pay a CEO
millions of dollars to Simply make
decisions about the company when the AI
will make better decisions so I think
you know in one version of this there is
no se Suite companies are run by AIS and
more efficiently and with
less less Humanity right because they'll
just make rational decisions but boy you
know that that's a you know be careful
of the question the question has an
embedded assumption that that the folks
who are asking it will still exist when
the answer
occurs wow well thank you I mean I agree
with someone is a very thought-provoking
conversation I loved it I hope you all
um on the line loved it as well we're at
time um thank you Bill and Cynthia for
this interesting insightful conversation
like I said to everyone in the audience
live with us today thank you for all
your questions and super engaging
participation I want to remind you that
today's session was recorded and a link
to this will be sent and made available
to you all within a week have a great
day and um see you all next time thanks
so
much